welcome to the nanny state nation where
the government minds your own business
saggy pants fireplaces plastic bags
lightbulbs poker it's all been banned
somewhere same with keeping swine or
fowl at home feeding pigeons owning pit
bulls and chomping on foie gras or trans
fats a naughty little substance that
makes foods like this taste better say
you don't want to stop serving trans
fats in your restaurant they'll find you
if you don't want to pay the fine
because you think it's unfair and you
still serve trans fats they'll send the
police with their guns to arrest you
every little thing the government does
is backed up by guns and force in Dallas
these Veterans of Foreign Wars regulars
got raided by the cops for playing low
stakes poker it's enough to make you
hide in your den and play poker online
too bad that's banned too sometimes
things get unbanned Chicago recently
repealed it's flawed rob ban but usually
the bandwagon keeps rolling along
nothing's too important to be banned
selling kidneys is against the law
even though undoing the ban might save
thousands of lives
nothing's too silly to be banned yes
what can happen if you sell
bacon-wrapped hot dogs in LA without
expensive government approved equipment
it's $1,000 or six months in jail
this woman was thrown in the slammer for
45 days for that heinous crime
it's amazing how long some bands have
been around gay sex was illegal in 13
states up until 2003 trading with Cuba
that bands been around for nearly 50
years and even if they're uttered in the
middle of the night some words are still
networked no nose
smoking's been banned in all sorts of
places indoors outdoors near doors at
beaches casinos even private homes last
I checked I'm pretty sure I live in
America America smoking ban craze
started out and good old California so
many bands start there when you talk
about nanny state
that's what California is but is New
York City the new California let's see
smoking ban check trans fat ban check
bans on aluminum bats check ban on
straddling a bike wearing in light
skates or drinking coffee on the subway
check check
New York past a symbolic ban on the N
word and many council members threw
their support behind a ban on the words
ho and [ __ ] problem is a female dog is
still known as a you know you can say
[ __ ] here and you don't have to say
[ __ ]
so with New York's upper-crusty
Westminster Dog Show be muzzled and I
thought they were getting all ghetto on
me but they're talking about female dog
politicians just don't know when to say
when
outdoor grilling his ban in some places
would you believe some cities have tried
to ban fast-food restaurants from
opening one did so many of us turn into
ban happy busybodies imagine if we
outlawed everything that offends someone
would you want to live in that country
across the pond I think they found a
better way
a Scottish pub owner ban this guy
Alistair Darling from his watering hall
and he did it without using the force of
law now pubs across Great Britain have
signed on to ban Alistair Darling a
Facebook group devoted to the ban has
more than three thousand members no laws
passed anyone can follow the band or not
beautiful oh and don't feel too sorry
for mr. darling he's the politician who
just raised Britain's beer tax freeze
not TV
I'm drew Carey